This Travel Video PostCard was contributed by Vanessa Velez.
They fought the French, the Chinese, and the Americans,...
...but this determined South Asian country is, at last, independent.
The Vietnamese are resilient people.
In spite of their suffering,...
...they're also very friendly and warm and full of national pride.
In Vietnam, the old and the new live comfortably side by side.
Hanoi is elegantly French with beautiful tree-lined boulevards...
...and classic architecture.
The old quarters beckon.
The antiquated mazes of streets...
...filled with shops, outdoor restaurants and cafes captivate.
Ho Chi Minh city is vibrant and modern, bustling with street life.
Authentic markets, chic bars and stylish young women are visual delights.
Crossing the streets in Ho Chi Minh city is an adventure.
The traffic literally never stops, but don't panic.
Cross slowly, steadily and somehow the traffic goes around you.
Vietnam at peace, but still quite undiscovered by the West, is very welcoming.
Watch our other Travel Video PostCards.